The joe rogan experience
and I've known you forever.
I knew you back when you were having
a real hard time with standup,
which to me is fascinating because you
the only guy that I've ever met that was
having like a really hard time with
standup and then add a nowhere.
Like you hit a switch.
You went from having a hard time with
stand up to Beano fucking murderer.
We would,
it was almost like you like you fucking
pass through a doorway or something.
Like within two years of
you working at the store,
you just figured it out is figured it
out one night and we were up on stage and
we're were in the back rather
and you were up on stage.
We were watching you go like Damn
Joey Diaz just turn a fucking corner.
You just figured out how to be funny.
You figured out who you were up there.
It's really weird when
you get into anything.
There's always the Jesus of the improving.
Yeah.
Of coming here,
I'm showing up,
this is just isn't working,
and then one day out of
the fucking blue pop pow.
It just starts working and it's
really weird with stand up.
You don't want to go to sleep,
you want to go home and
keep riding and riding.
And then I became infatuated from 95 to
[inaudible] 98 but I had so many other
things going on.
You know what I'm saying?
I had so many fucking things going
on that I couldn't really focus,
focus and then I moved to La and
I had all of these distractions.
You have all these stupid distractions
when you first moved to La and you're a
comic age and sees this,
that this,
that,
and then one day you just,
something hits you and it goes,
these motherfuckers don't matter.
Nothing really matters.
I've got to go up there and speak what's
in my heart and you just start going
and little by little,
once you find your voice
you become a savage.
That's it.
It's like a,
it's like a shark tasting blood.
It's like anything else.
When you get that taste,
you just go after it and,
and you know the comedy store's
the fucking comedy store man.
Once you get into comedy store.
To me that's like,
you know John [inaudible],
that's the comedy store,
John Jacques Machado.
It's those up a high level that that's it.
It's a high level but
especially in the two thousands
down there there was,
there was a some intense comedy
that was going on for your company.
Ari coming up there and
you coming up there,
it was a really intense time
and you,
you go on stage and you get this.
We had confidence that
it's this fucking thing.
You just get stronger and stronger and
the more people you go up in front of it
because then in the beginning they
make you go up in front of people.
You know,
going up in front of Mitzi shore is nerve
wracking and going on after they put
you on after a lot of guys that were
really fun and you're going up in front of
Mitzi shore,
you have no idea what that does to
you at the six year mark going up.
I cannot describe it.
I've thought about it and I've written
about that experience thousands of times
and nothing was more like I blacked out.
I had a blackout to go in front of Mitzi
shore because I knew it was it for a
guy like me and Mitzi
shore turned me down.
You know what?
I was going to go back to boulder,
probably stab one of those
motherfuckers without come out.
I would just,
when you getting out now I would
have been institutionalized.
There's no turning back from that.
It would have crushed my ego.
Her,
her taking me gave me another
five year reprieve in my life.
I knew I got something to do for five
more years before I go to jail for killing
somebody.
Like that's how I fell.
Did you really feel like
you're going to do that?
Because when I met you,
I never got that from,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's one part of the part of the,
the,
the jump in my comedy was the day
I wrote her the letter and I said,
you can't scam me no more.
He want to take the kid,
take the fuck am I gonna fucking road.
You're talking about you called
her up one day and told him,
yeah,
I told her that,
you know,
that at the end of the
day and I was being this,
you know,
some people really can't handle the truth
and sometimes you have to tell them,
and I had a talk to her and then talk to
her again in [inaudible] 99 when I took
that change,
it was around 2000 and you met me in
[inaudible] 97 it took me about three
years,
but one day in [inaudible]
99 before I went to bed,
I was clean for a couple of days,
maybe three days.
And I went to bed early and I had my,
which to me,
and I said,
I'm not going to fuck with this no more.
It was one of these things that I
was going into the lion's mouth.
I had a walk on a fine line
with her because I wanted
to be a part of that kid's
life,
but it wasn't looking that
way and I wasn't gonna take
her shit no more than one
morning I got up mice in her room and I
went and got a calling card and I call
that motherfucker and I just laid it out
to her and I told her the opening line
was,
I'll never forget this,
that listen between you and I,
and she knew me.
I said,
you know,
if you want to fire,
I would not pass on you.
Only contact I'm having with
you is because of this child.
So I pay for a separate phone in her
room and I don't have to talk to you no
more.
Cause she wanted what was killing me at
that time when she wanted to take and
change the child's name.
And my position was when my father died,
my mom remarried.
My poor dad that died.
I had to keep his fucking name.
That was just something in my heart,
so I always felt that that's let her
become 18 I have to decide what the fuck
she wants to write that was eating
away at me and when they add no value,
a name didn't have a value to me and this
whole situation didn't have a valid to
me.
Once I analyzed it and said,
fuck this bitch and what she stands for,
I turned that corner because
I dropped luggage off.
There's nothing sometimes in comedy,
sometimes in life you're just
carrying around some luggage,
man,
it doesn't let you move.
The box is five feet,
but the door is only three.
Sorry motherfucker and you got to drop
that shit until you dropped that fucking
box.
You ain't going to go through that door.
Too many people get locked
into those relationships,
whether they're friendships,
friendships with former ex,
ex wife and husband,
whatever you want to call
that relationship axes.
But they're like to deer with
their fucking horns locked
together and they can't
separate and they fucking every game a
push pull they fuck with each other on
purpose.
You know,
I've known people that went through
horrible divorces where,
you know,
you could tell that like they would,
they would like be setting
up each other like,
you know,
fuck him,
make him pay more,
you know,
uh,
let's,
let's agree to one thing
and then change the terms.
Just keep,
keep the bills coming in.
And like,
I've heard people talk like
it's a horror show.
It's crazy.
Very,
and this is,
this was the bad end of the Joe that this
is the already add the job in boulder
that paid the most fit an
educated schmuck like me.
I was working for a sports adviser and
that you can make anywhere from 20 to
60,000 to football seasons,
six months.
You can make some cases.
That's insane.
There were some guys that
make a hundred grand.
That was,
I had a month in December.
I made 25 grand working
in the fucking phones.
You just got to get some fish.
Tibetans send you money.
Believe that is,
you're going to take them
through the fucking bowl season.
Listen Bro,
you want to make 50 it's going to
cost you 20 go to Western Union.
Send me 20,000 and we'll
talk about sending.
So they're basically buying your
knowledge on your knowledge,
but you have buying your bullshit.
It's bad Karma also.
Really?
But this is what I was doing,
so I knew this,
I knew this.
Aren't they come to la
but see short old pass me.
Maybe the Improv pass has been,
but my dream was Mitzi shore.
Who the fuck are you kidding?
My whole thing was the store from day
one people told me to go to the fucking
store and that's your house.
That was my fate.
If she turned me down,
I would have probably
gone back to Colorado.
Probably gotten to work over there.
You know,
you,
you done sets in Seattle,
you were doing and I couldn't
go back to go to Seattle.
I would've gone back to
Colorado and tried to be a dad.
And one day ago,
I know me one fucking day,
the car breaks down,
the snow went out.
You get one of those bill's
overdue bill and that's it.
You bump into this fucking book and it
gives you that attitude with his flip
flops on.
I was going to run over
this motherfucking,
I was gonna do 50 fucking years.
So you know what,
as much as I,
the comedy store has that much power in
my life that her parents came along at
the right time,
came along at the right time.
Do you think the people create that?
I mean that's like the big,
the big hippy,
new age,
uh,
argument about lives that you
create these possibilities in life,
that you,
you're responsible for all these
different events that are happening too.
They're not random events.
These are events that are sort of
created by your own intentions.
Yes.
Do you feel that sometimes,
absolutely.
One thing I learned was that
till you take responsibility,
you ain't gonna move forward.
There's mother fuckers
that get off the stage.
The audience sucks.
The sound that I watched
a guy eat the pie.
Fuck Shit.
Never quite fucking bombed.
Yeah.
And that's it.
And everything else.
And until you come through
that you can't really,
and that was big for me
that I believe that it,
listen,
I go to bed now,
I go home,
I put my feet up,
I watch the news and I
go to bed like nothing.
You know,
20 years ago I didn't
go to bed like nothing.
I had to shut my window a
certain way and close my door,
shut away.
And I couldn't leave the light on at
night because I owed money to a drug deal.
I robbed somebody.
I created all those scenarios,
didn't,
I didn't make that kidnapping up.
I went there with a gun.
I knew that I was doing,
but it's funny that how quick the
turnaround was between like 99 you know,
like it's,
it all just sort of stopped.
It all stopped luggage
and it kept stopping.
You know,
it kept stopping and keep getting better.
What you're telling me is that I never
did blog at after 2006 that's you're
trying to tell me who me.
That's you're trying to tell me.
Why would you say that?
The weirdest way to phrase that sentence.
I haven't done Boston.
One day I went home,
one day I went home with a chick.
So one day I went home and
just stopped doing book.
That's what you're trying to tell me.
That was done that again.
I'm saying about being a criminal.
No,
no,
no.
I'm busting your balls.
I can't believe what
I'm fucking telling you.
That's nice.
2006 one day I went,
oh Brian.
One day I went home and
just stopped doing cocaine.
No Rehab,
no hug.
I didn't call nobody.
I didn't piss my ear.
I didn't give my life to our the Oba game.
There was none of that shit.
He'll,
okay,
whatever the fuck that shit is,
he never go.
It was nothing,
whatever,
the Pho,
but game,
whatever the fuck that shit is.
So my point is that what
happened was I dropped,
I kept dropping the pain that I
had and that luggage that I add,
I forced it out.
I just didn't fucking stop doing drugs.
I overcame whatever it was
making me do those fucking drugs.
Society wasn't making me do drugs.
Obamacare.
How funny is that?
They found heroin in the
Bronx with Obamacare envelope.
Austin,
Boston man hysteric instead,
Obamacare on it was on heroin.
Obamacare,
like people would just let everything,
we create everything in a lot of wings,
and this is random things
that happen as well,
right?
Because I broke this.
Sometimes people wake up on
the wrong side of fucking bed.
They come at you and you got to stand
your fucking ground and you got to say no
bitch that people get their feelings hurt.
Yes,
but no,
I created a lot of the shit
that happened in my life.
There's no fucking way.
You also have to stop silliness or it'll
invade your life and ruin your quality
of life if you don't get you get upset
at people.
Sometimes there's times where people are
infringing on your happiness with your
bullshit bullshit.
And you're like,
listen man,
you need to learn your
own for your own good.
You need to learn that what you're
doing is like socially unacceptable.
You're,
you're passing it off on other people.
You're passing off this shitty reality
that you're trying to promote something
you,
you can get locked in a person like that,
as we were saying before,
with like bad relationships
and then all of a sudden,
like every day you're dealing
with this person's nonsense,
distortions and lies.
And it can never trust.
Like who was it your fault.
No,
it's never your fault,
right?
And it's never your fault.
It's always somebody else's fault.
And when you deal with people like that
on a regular basis and you communicate
with people like that,
it makes it incredibly difficult for
you to live your life because you're
constantly,
you're constantly like debating
or dismissing bullshit.
Like,
is this bullshit?
It might be bullshit.
And then somewhere along the line,
you fuck this man,
I got to stop hanging
out with this person.
This person's an asshole.
You know,
that person doesn't give
a fuck about the truth.
They don't give a fuck about me.
That is,
and I've had a few of those in my life.
And you just cut them loose
and when you cut them loose,
like you're a way better person,
you like your life is free and easy.
And I'm like,
oh,
it's not that.
I'm like constantly engage in conflict.
It's that if you surround yourself
with the wrong kind of people,
you will be constantly
engaged in conflict.
Whether you want it or whether
you have that intention or not.
Like it's not just about
having the right intentions,
you gotta make the right choices
as to who you put in your world.
Because if you put a bunch of shitheads
that don't care about evolving,
they don't care about getting it together.
And all the trying to do is
pass off of nonsense on you.
Oh,
you've got to fucking,
you got a Shitty road.
You've got a Shitty road ahead of you
did.
I used to love guns?
I wasn't a gun up like your buddy,
but I loved guns.
I loved having them.
I love them.
And the same thing.
One day I was like,
every time I carry a
gun there's a problem.
Yes.
Put that out there almost.
Right?
It's like a magnet for other guns and
you're not the only one that says that.
It's like a magnet.
I'm telling you when I carried a gun,
I carry the Gulf for a very short
time because I didn't like it.
I didn't see the purpose for it.
It's a nice thing could use
to try to be a tough guy,
but all it's going to do is
get you a fucking trouble.
Cause you pull that motherfucker wanting
motherfuckers going to pull their mind.
You that real tough guys.
And I knew that going in.
I fucking knew it.
I wanted to fire it at somebody.
But I tell you what man,
it was amazing how he used
to go home at night and go,
what the fuck just happened tonight?
Why did I have to go from my
reach for my gun through it?
Why were they six other people in
the room and a coke party with guns?
Because guns attract.
They're like fucking magnets.
And one day I got rid of all those guns.
It was like I lost 80
fucking pounds of drama.
The same thing 10 years ago,
this phone would be ringing with people
that were asking me questions about,
you know,
how do you get roadwork?
You know,
why don't you take me on the fucking road?
you can all these fucking people calling
you with these questions and at the
same time they have low concern for you.
They really don't.
They're just trying to pull you down,
especially in this fucking town.
If you let people pull you down,
but I don't know what you're doing.
It's not happening for me.
What do you want?
What do you want me to do?
You got like right and get
on stage every fucking night.
What'd you do as well?
I went to my sister's wedding.
Well go fuck your mother.
Then go to the fucking wedding.
You were one of the last guys that picking
that out to you were one of the best
guys.
Birds might fucking core that people
come up to you and put their lack of Vr.
That I saw somebody,
but I started comedy with
at the store 13 years ago.
I was going to screen or some
stupid movie that my buddy was in.
My wife was sleeping.
I said,
let me go down there.
And as I was walking around the corner,
her,
Joey and I went up and I go,
I didn't even know who was.
And he was telling me what he
was doing in front of their,
and he was,
you hear about us.
Well,
and he was telling me,
you know,
what he was doing there and what he was,
where he was working.
And I drove back to fucking studio city
with like tears in my eyes because he
had every opportunity that I had.
He was a good luck and knew when
he moved to this fucking town.
But the ham,
he used to go to the store and
drank and everything was high.
And now I'm supposed to feel guilty on
the fucking one o one cause this fucking
schmucks got a job working until
fucking two in the morning.
Parking cars or something,
you know,
I mean,
we all had the same opportunities here.
Well,
there's people that feel like those
people in your life to teach you that
lesson.
To see people fail and have regrets and
see people not give 100% or not give it
all their focus or give
it all their honesty,
you know,
give it,
give it who the fuck you really are.
We see those people and that regret is
almost there to let us know like don't
ever let that happen.
As I was getting in my car,
he made a coat and he
was one of those guys.
I always had to have that
one comment that the store,
they may like a fucking comment.
I just want to say
something about something.
It must have been nice to
them blow all those years,
like something just,
you know what I'm saying?
Like he's one of those guys that
he's going to pull you down,
right?
He had a,
and I just got in the car and I said,
you know,
this is why that guy's
parking cars and you know,
I'm on the fucking road work and at
least trying to make things happen.
This is why this guy's parking.
Fucking
there was a guy that I want to,
I won't mention his name,
but you,
uh,
you had warned me about
him a long time ago,
long before it ever went real bad form.
And then one time I was back in the east
coast and the guy hadn't done comedy
and he fucking the couple of years and
he's like trying to get ahold of me to
open up for me.
Like,
what are you just,
you just got to get back on stage after
a couple of years and open up at the big
show.
Like really that's where you're
going to do a Yeti fucking mind.
Like what kind of weird request is that
you have an uncommon in two years you
want to go up and a in
front of a sold out club.
Like that's,
that's ridiculous.
Like why would you think that you
could just do that like you get,
but that's what they,
there's a lot of guys that didn't make
any comedy that felt like they didn't
make it because nobody helped him.
And I've heard that so many times.
I've heard that stupid argument like I
wasn't there when the right group or if
you're not in with the right group.
It's very hard to get roadwork like,
what are you talking about?
What do you all you
have to do is be funny.
If you're funny,
people find you.
It's,
it's one of the easiest
businesses of all time.
You get proven onstage for sure.
Easiest to understand.
This is how easy it works.
You'll go onstage,
you get to people to laugh,
people notice.
Then they started offering your work.
It's that simple.
When you prove that you have a certain
amount of time and you prove that you can
consistently perform really well.
People want to give you some work.
They give you a little here,
they give you a little there.
You make some connections,
you start networking.
The next thing you know you started,
you know,
moving in your area a little bit,
getting a few gigs here and there and
it takes fucking years and you've got to
keep doing it.
If you don't keep doing it,
then you really didn't want to do it.
But if you do keep doing it,
you get to a point where you're Joey
Diaz and if you're one of those guys that
didn't really want to do it,
and one day you see Joey Diaz and he said,
it moves been good folk.
Do Cocoa lose yours.
You're there.
You're like a living
lesson.
Like that guy's like a little,
a little stop on your journey.
I broke my foot book,
it broke my on the drive home.
I was like,
wow.
And when I had the same opportunities,
we both walked into that store,
he used to get spots,
he was good.
He was decent.
Yeah.
Showed potential whatever,
nine o'clock spots,
a couple of belly room spots,
and now you're out here fucking 11
o'clock at night and you're like,
wow.
Yeah.